et aujourd'hui ça va être à toi de jouer
à ce qu'il y a trois boîtes ce soir je
vais demander à stella à ludivine et a
hâte de monter sur scène à léo
[Applaudissements]
vous allez vous passer chacun devant une
boîte dans chacune des boîtes se
trouvent à cadeaux il ya une boîte ou
lien séjour en bord de mer pour tout le
public aux îles via une boîte où il ya
une merguez pour tout public
il ya un indice il ya une boîte où il ya
un cadeau surprise
peut-être peut-être mieux que ce séjour
au moins bien julien tu vas devoir
choisir la boîte une la boîte de ou la
boîte 3 à la la julien l'a tout de suite
est-ce que je vais laisser parler mon
coeur je laisse aux verts ludivine que
je vais aller parce que je suis attiré
par son personnage sa gentillesse enfin
combien acajou par ludivine donc tu
prends la une pour l'instant je prends
la une je pense que c'est là dedans
quels julien le banquier vous propose
d'échanger votre poids
du coup si le banquier me demande
d'échangé c'est qu'effectivement il ya
peut-être un problème j'ai donc partir
sur l'a3 alors ils ne savent pas ce cas
dans les boîtes aurait dit tu oublies
toi non plus d'ailleurs j'ai
l'impression oui vous le confirme
tu vois qu'il voit qu'il a travaillé
avec moi je repasse sur l'a3 je vais
vous dire il ya peut-être un cadeau pour
tout le public un voyage très las de
élimine la boîte numéros unes avec
ludivine ludivine d'un jour au change
ludivine ouais donc à ce qu'il est c'est
fait je rechange tu gardes ta boîte pour
l'instant ok je te sens bien moi il n'y
aurait pas été choisi par julien courbet
nom puis un an mais le banquier vous
propose des achats chez votre boîte à
nouveau je vous le dis il ya un voyage à
la mode et à ludivine oui d'ouvrir sa
boîte et de voir ce qu'il y avait dedans
est ce que c'est le voyage
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le colle à la peau attendez il ya une
boîte ou d'un voyage pour tout public
il ya une boîte où il ya une merguez
pour tout public julien tu as choisi
quelle boîte mon deuxième choix c'était
la 3 julia a choisi la boîte numéro 3
vous préférez quoi le public
[Applaudissements]
julien tu as choisi la boîte numéro 3 je
pense que dans la boîte numéro trois au
juge qu'elle voyait le voyage pour tous
les publics
donc tu penses que cette personne
symbolise les merguez pas du tout pas du
tout mais j'ai plutôt j'ai préféré me
projeter plutôt que me reprocher sur la
merguez du monsieur j'éprouve un voyage
à glozel on accomplit
ase
series je vais demander à stella
d'ouvrir sa boîte c'est la boîte peut
être gagnante pour tout le public
si dans cette boîte si dans cette boîte
il ya une merguez tous plus mais gagnera
une merguez
si dans cette boîte il ya quelque chose
d'autre chose qui symbolise le voyage
tout public partir en vacances julien tu
es sûr tu gardes la 3 way fait certes un
certain point de faire confiance j'ai
déjà eu du nez avec les ud direct pour
l'instant t pas mal c'était là je vais
te demander
d'ouvrir la boîte attendez je vais très
perspicace oui
le banquier vous propose une dernière
fois d'échanger votre boîte
excuse-moi telle enquête doit justement
savoir je te connais un petit peu de
banquiers candidats attaquant passait
bien je reste sur mon choix
tu restes sur celle ci et là c'est parti
[Musique]
emma l'occasion une merguez il a une
merguez pour tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
ottawa à ses jours
vous avez perdu ses jours
vous pouvez échanger votre merguez et à
force de des changes peut-être partir en
voyage les ferries peut pas gagner voilà
c'est le seul